[Music]
we good
action we need an action give me an
action action
action
the first 45 minutes of this podcast is
just are we good are we good good
are we rolling guys are we good can i
get an action wait a minute are we good
no do people know that they do now
should we like post people know a lot
we're gonna get into it
people know way more than we think i
know this the confluence of like the
little
smidgen of ocd and perfectionism and
uh unhinged everything i'm so
um it takes me a while to start
something nikki glazer is on the podcast
today which is
our she is the second
uh round tour yeah twice
on good for you taylor thomson was on
twice nikki glazed on twice
back by popular demand popular demand
very probably she's a great comedian
she's been on netflix
this is a very different uh
interview than our first one we were
like two puppies that
got to play for the first time because
there is this like
you know east coast west coast
rivalry and comedy i'm sorry i'm just
gonna say it like there's a little bit
of it
is that you're not lifting a curtain
people know i do people know that i'm
sure like it's just nikki and i never
there was a little
competition there was a little like we
just we were
it's very clicky comedy is very clicky
like all things in life yeah we weren't
allowed to like really be
friends for a long time and um
who uh i mean just the forces that be
the comedy forces that be new york and
california they're so far apart
it's really geography there was sort of
this little mean girls thing happening
and then um
and so our first one was like we vaginas
vaginas dicks dicks dicks dicks dicks
like we
just like went nuts like two tasmanian
devils
like monkeys in a barrel and then
this one was i think a little more calm
and chill and like
we became like real friends yeah it was
more like it was more
personal intimate yeah yeah and honest
because i think
comedians like which is why i love
podcasting is like
we always want to be funny and make you
guys laugh but she wasn't performing
yeah no one was being fake this is a
good interview
yeah yeah um but there's a couple things
we want to get to
before um nikki glazer
uh notes i would like some notes
some feedback i love a note i know that
uh a lot on this podcast so people don't
read the comments
i want to make this podcast i'm not the
i've been in the hollywood show business
land for a long time where a bunch of
people give you notes they
i don't give a fuck what anyone thinks
except the fans
i want you guys to be my boss and tell
me what you like
tell me what you don't like i work for
you what are your fucking notes what do
you want what do you hate
me we looked at the youtube comments
specifically it was really filled with
actual constructive criticism and
we i did not hold back i screenshotted
the ones that were
just as rough so we're gonna start off
and this is probably
ninety percent of comments on every
video not over exaggeration give it to
me
and most of them are about uh whitney
you're in inter you think that you
interrupt whenever you are bored it's
extremely disrespectful to the guests
that you have brought on also as a
viewer
i want you to know that none of us are
actually bored we actually enjoy
hearing the other people's thoughts or
else we wouldn't have clicked on the
video
this comment has 576 likes out of 400
comments so more people like the comment
than comment on the video
so what so what's the top line
the top line is i think that they want
you to stop talking so much
because the next comment that also has
785 likes says
whitney you do know that everything is
not about you every story does not have
to end with a story about you
okay they said we've been a huge fan for
years i guess there's somebody with them
a partner
have been a huge fan for years this is
just constructive criticism i i
i do love hearing about you but not when
the guest is there
copy and then also says i hear this
i'm hearing you whitney if you would
like to cancel words please stop saying
the word ancestral
cancelled uh and anything about the
brain we get it you love science but
every
other people are are here for the
entertainment
okay so talk less
be funnier um but i mean
what's the most consistent criticism the
most consistent criticism is that you
are um not likable
because you are mean to the people from
the podcast i mean and that you
are you interrupt too much and you make
the stories about yourself
yeah okay i will say that none of these
comments
mention the way you look none of these
comments are saying that that you're
unfunny that's not them
every comment starts to end basically
but i'm a huge fan of yours i just want
you to know this is how you appear
this is like so helpful it is literally
how you appear yeah and then there was a
comment which i don't know if i can try
but there's a comment that said
whitney you've went to a platform where
the opinion you went to a platform where
the opinion of the viewer matters most
if you don't want our opinion go back to
tv so that way your show
can be canceled when you don't listen
and they were like and they were like we
are here to actually and then they ended
it with like i have followed your whole
career you're my favorite comedian
i really want you to keep this going
because i love your questions but you
don't let anyone answer the question
but they did but then you i will say you
also have a huge number i would say
almost as many that say that you
interrupt as saying that whitney asks
the best questions i just want to hear
the answer
i'm just a spaz yeah but i mean these
are all things that are like
because you know what i i'm always
i'm not going to defend myself i i agree
this is something i really want to work
on
i've got to fix this about myself
you know yeah and then i will say that
like i get so excited and
i i mean i did go on prozac like
because i know i have the add thing i'm
not educated enough to really understand
it but
about that um and the
the smidgen of ocd but like i just when
i think so
maybe i should start writing things down
well the people that come to
not your defense but the people that
counteract these arguments say that you
know you are a comic
the people that you are a comic so a lot
of times comics are waiting to insert
something funny or something new
yeah and they're not always listening
because they're used to to watching and
then waiting to
when to strike with a joke or another
comment right right and they were like
so maybe that's it and that and
and a lot of people say like i'm going
to hold out and give this time to
evolve because that is probably a very
different transition to go from being an
onstage headlining to going to have to
to be a talk show host that's two
different things i mean i used to be so
bummed when i would go on late night
talk shows
and have my bit all ready to go and then
the
talk show host would interrupt or cut me
you know like or steal the
you know like that's the olden times
of the small the silver screen yeah and
then this comment
okay this comment is new 2021 dude i am
gonna fucking
figure this out it is a bit um
uncomfortable to watch this podcast
every now and then or even listen to it
not everything is a therapy session not
everyone needs to be a pathologist
pathologist um it is actually possible
for you to have a fun
interesting conversation with someone
without talking about neurology the
subconscious
ancestors trauma or etc am i born we
absolutely love when you have those
discussions with guests that they fit
we want you to know that your curious
mindset is the reason that we tune in
because your questions
are fascinating but we really really
really need you to let the person
finish the finish the question you often
times
will ask a question and then throw out
five or six possible answers in which
they can choose from
and then move on to a different topic
like i'll answer i'll ask a question
mona
sorry that's my dog so i'll ask a
question and answer it for them
yeah i hate that shit um
come at me um this is from the zoe okay
wait no hold on i need a minute
whoa i need a minute to unpack it all
um so marching orders for me are
shut my hole pie hole
mid-speed pie hole well not even that
they want you to keep asking your
questions they want you to keep doing
that
they're just running a breath yeah you
know what i hate i hate when people go
um when people ask questions to
themselves
like you know when someone goes um uh
and why would i do that i do that
because i just
really want to build a business like you
know when people ask themselves
questions yeah
like yeah they asked an answer for me
and i'm doing that
no well i mean a lot of it they say um a
lot of the comments do also express
they're like we understand that this is
this is your way of dealing with the
things that you've talked about you've
had to deal with
deal with but then um but then there's
also
many i'm looking at all there's many
comments that also say like
um you don't have to always talk about
what happened bad to you we would love
to know about the good things in your
career oh great
great great great let's do that and then
also the open circuits start being funny
we're bringing people on and i'm gonna
have uh we're gonna have jokes though
well the opens are
the comment there they are they don't
there's no complaints about the opens
oh i oh well i just want it to be
funny too i want to make a fucking i
mean every almost
everything about the length is it too
long they get well they said they'll
come back and finish them sometimes they
have to look the guests up a lot they
don't know who they are okay well okay
this is it everyone's saying that i need
to intro the guests
yeah are they not am i not do i not have
famous enough well one of the comments
said for someone who doesn't want people
to um to uh say everyone or
all the people it's really strange that
you think we all know who
oh y'all are just smarter than me
that's the problem and well i remember
that kind of
comment they wrote i learned that from
you that's funny yeah but it's just
i i don't want to wait i hate i can't
stand it when i
um watch a show and someone's like you
know her from this show and this show
and this shit it's like yeah no
i know that's why i'm watching it you
know i assume everybody
knows everyone and i also want you guys
to just trust me
yeah i'm not going to book anyone that's
not going to be fascinating i bet a lot
more
i bet a lot of people do know who they
are but i think that also
i think the people who are probably
coming this are new or people are new
fans who are finding the podcast
or are listening only on audio because
there are so many people that are famous
to somebody or that are important to
somebody that's hard to say who we all
know because now people
before everyone knew marilyn monroe
there's only so many stars i know now
it's like there's such a like you either
have never heard of someone or you know
what they had for breakfast
so it's like fame is so weird now
someone that's super famous that i've
never heard of
well there was one that said whitney you
are young please stop saying you are not
young
i just don't want to record whitney with
younger guests you do know that
often you are not even that far from
their age there is no need to talk down
to them you probably have a lot in
common but we won't ever find out if you
won't let them answer the question
y'all are coming for me make me better
make me better thank you thank you thank
you
um helpful feedback none of us are bored
nice i just like i yeah i know and it's
like my favorite part of the podcast i
listen to are just like
you know i like the ads i like listening
to billboard read ads
you know yeah we have a lot of comments
about our ads too uh
okay so okay so new year i am going to
interrupt less
i am going to intro the guests and give
a proper intro
so you guys know what you're about to
listen to because my first i've only
been podcasting for a year
guys i'm trying i don't i'm i'm finding
my groove thank you for sticking yeah a
lot and a lot i mean a lot of the
comments also mention that that we're
finding the groove i mean these are i'm
just going through these in real life
right now yeah
and these are in real life uh yeah in
real time not for you guys but for us
um and i mean these are there's
a thousand comments on here and so far
all every top comment is about
interrupting or about um
your attitude towards the people on the
show me or other guests
attitude yeah it says i mean every
almost every comment
but i would also like a bully i'm a
bully uh
this show should have been called good
for me
why and then it says whitney quotation
me me me
me me me oh jesus um okay
okay the highlights are just i mean okay
let me ask you let me just
stop you right there would people say
this to bill burr or joe rogan
um some examples or a lot of people
bring up joe rogan
about how he never speaks he never has
an example
he always lets the guest talk and he
says barely anything that's not true
always anything they say and then um
exaggerations
and then the other comments do you think
anyone would say this to bill burr
well the other comments are if you want
to do a podcast about yourself do it
alone stop having guests
jesus christ but then yeah the top notes
are just like no interrupting
no therapy you're talking about yourself
okay no projecting
okay and no bullying i'm still figuring
it out because it's like
stand up i know what makes people like
you go in involuntary laughter i know
what to do yep
you because the fans are the boss sure
forget hollywood
studio heads and casting direct forget
all that
like i want to go to the people that are
like
driving their kids to school and doing
their laundry and doing their chores
at the gym and running around and with
me like when i started whitney gave me a
lot of really good feedback about like
you know this isn't this isn't going to
work on
camera or this isn't going to work
whenever you speak or you're like or
like i had gerds and i would have like
gurgles yeah it's like a it's like a
it's like acid reflux and it makes you
have these noises and on microphone it
sounds really weird so i wouldn't have
checked out like those are all things
that would have been really offensive to
me if they weren't actually helpful
and so my brand is you'll thank me later
this sounds mean now
but you'll thank me later yeah that's my
whole thing
yeah yeah i i know this sounds i seem
like i'm being a bully right now but
i've done that i've been there let me
just save you some time
that was like the cassie david interview
yes which in the cassie david interview
the top note of that is i was a bully
well that's the top note of a lot of
them but the top note of that one was
that um people like you
because you're funny and because you're
interesting and because you're
someone like successful that they can
look up to not because you're broken
nice but i like to just make sure
everyone knows that
you can come for brokenness and and then
do that do it do what we're doing right
now if you take the constructive part of
that comment it's that we know that now
it's been mentioned
so much we got it i don't yeah so
insecure i can assume
that nobody listens to every episode
yeah and i wasn't hurt as a kid here we
go
uh and so i assume i have to repeat
myself over and over again i don't need
to do that anymore
yeah people fuck with me fuck with me
yeah because of people i mean because it
goes back to that thing like because
we had this conversation before remember
the conversation about how like if
something's always happening to someone
eventually it's them
yeah yeah so if we're getting the same
feedback then obviously we want to like
shift that
so it's the best show possible i'm like
i'm like a
aunt i'm like your aunt i mean i'm my
aunt from
virginia you know i'm like i'm gonna
fucking
make you better it's also just like i'm
a coach that's like my
inherent thing yes well i wish i would
there was
i looked for it if we wanted to hear it
but there was a comment that was about
um
whitney's giving these people really
good advice it's her delivery is poor
i i'm condescending patronizing but you
also have to remember that whitney is
also a comedian and the comics talk like
that yeah that's right
one of the things we've had a lot of
women on women can handle it
it sounds you can handle it that's the
other thing which people start pitting
someone that i'm saying you need to stop
doing that
like that seems mean but when you think
that's mean
you're assuming that women are weak you
can't handle the truth
we could handle it i think it feels like
i wish i think when i was 26 or whatever
i wish i was like stop fucking doing
that cut it out
that's why george is my therapist she
was like no done you're done
yeah i trained animals that's that's you
it's all body language
you have to mean what you say and say
what you mean and that is what
and not say it mean that's the last part
of that that's it not say it mean
but like i'm very direct and clear and
and i think that that's
fair and respectful to the other person
because you're
saying you can handle it but the
comments get confused because the guest
is not speaking to you like that
so it looks one-sided i mean my guests
fight me
allison brief fought me well not in a
way not in the way that this one fought
me
appearing that way at least oh really
they're always like nope whitney you're
wrong
i mean i think like i don't think
anyone's i don't think i bulldozed
anyone
billboard fucking fought me yeah
yeah yeah i mean i think it's just a
woman acting like a
having trouble i think traits no i think
it's just
seeing it we see you every time we only
see the guests once or twice oh yeah
so it's going to look one-sided because
because you're seeing well why would
they come if they if i they didn't like
if i was
you know no one leaves here like feeling
bruised and broken
well probably not yeah it's like
sparring i mean most i mean those all
people come on here are very successful
too
they can handle it but as a i mean
you're getting to the in the space of
fans so now
fans don't want to think that they're
supporting someone who is
a bully and they also don't want to
think that the person that they love
they're coming to watch is being bullied
oh no it goes back to the time we live
in i just want i just don't want good
people get
good things i just don't want to ask
questions that every other fucking show
asks
yeah i mean that is what was it like
working with brad pitt
no but also you can get critique on your
questions your questions were multiple
times said they were great questions
okay okay we have to go
uh uh nikki glazer's here
you're probably going to think i'm
bullying her no i don't think so
if you think that in this episode though
you didn't watch it 21 i'm gonna address
your notes
keep sending them we're gonna do more
voicemails um be more consistent with
opens
more i'm gonna bully benton more he's
gonna be in the opens more
i'm going to i'll have a black eye next
time
will that help like subscribe please and
don't ride elephants i love you guys
nikki glazer
order me food you order me food
no you have your phone out i don't have
my phone out so you can order doordash
on your phone but it's on my home page
when when good place to get it when
something makes my
like home screen on my phone
that's the business it truly is because
you know there's other pages
i don't mess around when it comes to
eating is so exhausting oh
it's just like it it's such a hassle to
think about it
to the the into this and i have the
thing the choice is our hassle yeah yes
not the actual especially in these
coveted times
doordash just takes takes i feel like
we're all spinning
so many plates no pun intended
and doordash just takes a plate off one
less plate to spin
see i think door just gives me all my
options so that when i i can i can
figure out how i feel
i don't have to be forced into one thing
like like like you know like normally
it's like what's close to me what can i
go get myself
donation will bring me whatever i want
you know what i think it is what it's an
argument now
i think it's something called magic oh
i would like chinese food boom at your
door it's like christmas morning
i'm sure some of the employees are named
magic that bring the food
but i i think that it is the wonderful
employees at doordash that give
safe contactless deliveries to me
contactless
they're the real heroes honestly and
like i
i feel like my doordash people
are annoyed by me because i was like how
are you what's up what are you doing
i want to talk to them they're like can
you just take it they were like i'm
leaving this here and backing away yeah
i'm like hi
how's everything do you want to come in
they're like we love doordash and right
now
every horror movie starts right now our
listeners get five dollars off their
first order of 15
or more and zero delivery fees for their
first month when you download doordash
app and enter code whitney that's five
dollars off your first order and zero
delivery fees for a month when you
download the doordash app in the app
store
and enter code whitney don't forget
that's codewhitney for five dollars off
your first order with doordash
look i think it's obvious that i don't
need help
i think it's obvious that i'm better
i just tickle myself fancy with that one
benton had his first
therapy appointment today which isn't
personal at all
you guys want to talk about it am i
going to out you publicly
again your therapy journey um
yeah but better help is a great
alternative for if
you you know want to do therapy on your
own time because better help
will match you with licensed
professional therapists and you can
start talking under 48 hours
can i stop you can i stop you i just
feel
like a lot of famous successful
celebrities talk about therapy as if
everyone
has the time and the money
or in the right location to even go yeah
in what world
you know there are places that don't
have therapy you know west virginia
oh just go to therapy like it's so
elitist
but if you have a computer and you can
get some
wi-fi world wide web internet
yeah or if you have a phone you don't
even need a computer or if you have a
library with a computer
yes yes there's lots of ways to get in
touch with better help get better help
you can get therapy
and their services are available
worldwide it's not elitist
not anymore visit betterhelp.com whitney
that's better h-e-l-p
and join over 1 million people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
50 states is that yep although it's dc
still state
oh there's 50 states yep special offer
for example see a state though
no but
i'm from d.c no there's 50 we don't know
there's 50 states
i have a problem with this 50 states
thing okay
well i'm just saying it's too late now i
just feel like
50 is it 50 states plus washington d.c
oh no we went to an ivy league college
and they also put stars on the flag to
remind us that there are 50.
plus puerto rico puerto rico is not a
state it's just part of why
okay so special offer for good for you
listeners get 10 percent off your first
mind
i at betterhelp.com go right now no no
you need a tutor
[Laughter]
are we on the ham radio
um you're our only
second guest since taylor tomlinson
really
thank you i was like so excited you
asked me so soon back
back by popular demand people love us
why i i got so much good response from
it and it was
i was like fascinated by our discussion
i had like blacked out
during i disassociated i loved watching
it back i don't usually like watching
things back but i was like oh they're
good together
like we're the best
and it's like yeah i don't i
it was a love fest for sure and it just
really solidified something for me about
you like i just
it just felt really good and sincere and
i just felt
great about you after it i love that you
have boundaries and
are an open book thanks the boundaries
thing i still
struggle with yeah i just want to people
please you know
who you be why i mean
i still i like when we were just in your
bedroom and you were like changing and
we were talking i was like
wait are you comfortable right now like
are you being yourself and i was like
yeah i think i am like i'm really like
this is like how i would be around my
sister
like and that isn't always the case
especially with like a new friend
especially whitney cummings are we new
friends
i feel like yeah yeah i mean like we've
we've always known each other but
we're fine i had a lot to unpack yeah it
was it was always gonna be surface if we
ran into each other like huh
you know just i feel like when i went to
each other
our um voices went up
oh my god and then you turn into a
pretzel
yes yes
i can go into that sometimes with you
like i
yeah i just there i want you to like me
i'm just gonna admit it like
i i desperately want you to like me but
if i
do say like you do believe me yeah i'm
yeah i do
i do because i have nothing to offer you
okay so i like how you were like hey i'm
gonna think of some things and then you
go
no that's that's spot on no i really
don't that's why i i
i trust it um and there's no reason why
you
yeah it's it feels real we have a lot in
common you tell me things that i feel
like
wow she really trusts me to not
divulge this to anyone else like we have
a there's a trust there and i've told
you some crazy shit
yeah just like minutes ago while you
were naked
all right like you just like took off
your top
it was like that was to me getting to
see you
topless was a treat
and i stopped myself from being like
you're like you're in you looking
insanely good like you're just
like what
okay yes oh yeah um i wanted to like
just
shower you with compliments about how
good you look and like topless how like
amazing you look naked look at you what
it's about you because you were naked in
front of me and like i never see
my like i don't see people naked a lot
my friends i mean i do but i have
sisters
you have a sister but we don't get naked
in front of each other that often
and she lives away and i just like that
um i don't know we just never got naked
in front of each other i think
as a ch okay you want to go there as a
child yeah that's what we do here
i oh my god i've really never said this
we can cut it
okay let me just say it um i think i
developed like you know like when you're
a a little girl like your vagina's just
like just a slit
you know like it was just like it's just
a baby vagina
until you like mature and then things
start like moving around on there
things are growing like it gets more
bulky and i remember taking a bath with
my sister when we were kids and my
sister does listen to this podcast so
yes i remember this i don't think we've
ever talked about it lauren love you
she's amazing and she
saw my vagina that had probably like my
clitoral hood
you know like the bump over the clit
that looks like an
old jk hood yeah like yes you know the
thing you have to lift to find your clit
i had that and she was like nikki you
have a penis
and i don't even have a big clit like
it's that's not a it's that would be
a whole other story but i just she was
like you have a penis and she told my
mom
and i was like in fifth grade and it was
really damaging so i was like i shall
never get naked in front of her again
um because she might reveal like she
might see my balls
my adam's apple why is that funny
[Laughter]
why who cares because
it's funny because we uh
all have had some iteration of that yes
yes
it is relatable and that's that's the
honesty thing that i
i i yeah i get i i i like to talk about
these things that and
it's rare that i come across one that
i'm like i've never shared this and it's
making me nervous
and that's very exciting to me because i
feel like sometimes i've just
said it all you know do you ever feel
like i have no more stories i've no more
secrets
and that to me is one that i've buried
so deep and haven't talked about but i'm
so glad to do it because
that's the shit when you share something
like that that's when you get the dms of
like
i thought i was the only one and like
and
that's all i want to do my dm's are all
dicks
so in towels blackouts guys right now i
thought i was the only one guys with
black towels
i know guys so they don't have to wash
them
guys it's so smart every guy has a black
towel
behind their dick like they're they're
giving
taking their photo there's like a ramen
noodle
and a black towel and like a loofah
and i i can tell you based on your dick
pic
what stage of a relationship you're in
oh wow
so usually these guys are in
relationship if there's a sliver of an
irish spring
it's so single yes if there's uh
uh a comet cleaning
like you're single i got it but if
there's like a bath and body works
a shower caddy blue mary of any sort uh
like
oh my god cucumber melon just a classic
there's like a body shop mango body
butter
i like your eggs
wild yeah so what were we
even saying yeah you seem happier than
the last time i saw you
palmer fucking happier dude calmer i'm
medicated
properly tell and i'm like tell me i've
just like had a lot of breakthroughs i
um i got diagnosed with adhd what which
is
not tell me the a the h and the a and
the d
um i don't even know i think it's
hyperactive is the
adult addition deficit hyperactive
disorder do i have that
probably i'm not joking you called
dr joe rogan does ritalin make you
focused
i've never taken riddle you haven't no
or adderall adderall i've taken
okay so i wrote my book on adderall okay
there you go yeah you you have it
well that's not and that's obviously not
the determining factor but i had to go
in
i was having terrible depression over
the summer and i've had bouts of it
throughout my life but like
suicidal thoughts how like tell me the
thoughts
kill yourself wow uh gun
uh i just have images of myself it
wasn't uh there was no
context to it it would just be like an
image of me going like this like they
would just
i'd be like it's i've compared it to
when you get sick and you start getting
sniffles the first sign of like i have
the flu
if i have an image of a gun like putting
a gun to my head i'm like oh fuck uh
depression's coming god
fucking damn it and it it's not even
like i'm like i'm gonna go
think about killing myself it just is an
invasive thought
and it's it's the blink of an eye like
it happens very fast but i'm just like
oh no here it comes and then it
and then comes the immense um
just there's no point to anything i'm
i've tricked everyone into thinking i'm
talented i have nothing to offer this
world would we
i used to i kind of got away from that
too i want to talk about that but anyway
yeah i got
weed i was medicating with weed to make
me feel better because i would instantly
feel this like
it wouldn't make me tired it would make
me want to talk and like be excited
about the world and i was just
and then i started having just a really
bad memory
whatever you got i mean like i would
take the the upper so
it's in the couch and sat up in the
couch i don't know
you're the couch for both of them so um
yeah i was medicating with wheat i could
not stop doing
just smoking every day during the
pandemic and
my memory was being affected so much
yeah and i was doing it before the
pandemic show i was like a
dud i was useless yeah when you so you
had like a year of a lot of weed smoke
and how
we smoking and how did you get into it
like how did you fall into that i was
just
i had migraines and just
general malaise as women
we just have pain all that i look like
the world from labyrinth
um
so i was doing these vapes
to fight and we passed the veins i mean
it really is like we have
chosen a lifestyle that
kind of recreates our childhood
circumstances in terms of
like alcohol comb you 8 p.m that's when
shit
hits the fan pick mom up get the
tell go tell the neighbor everything's
fine everything's sorry about that sorry
we hit your mailbox sorry we drove it
you know
it's a it's dark dude mailbox it's
real dark and i've had a mailbox
incident with
mom mom in the mail of course and uh
sorry about it sorry that i threw we
were screaming in the yard
um everything we're play acting whatever
the lies
so where does we come into this for you
oh sorry sorry um
uh not on it now shockingly this is
actually my personality
um uh i
was would go to uh tempe improv and
you know whatever where i was going uh
addison improv
when i was because i like to run my
specials in clubs
because that's how you really know rest
in peace clubs
um and i
needed it to sleep also at night it was
the time when you if you grew up in an
alcoholic home that's when you got
molested sorry
nighttime was the time when you had to
be on high alert hyper vigilant
what's happening whose footsteps are
those like you had to be you know
yeah mom crashing glasses breaking
phones being thrown
yeah um also this was uh i talked to
dr david agus about this that
the night watcher theory which i bring
up a lot
of um in tribal times when we uh
were the people that stayed up all night
to protect the tribe
bread right and they
were their circadian rhythms were
essentially inverted
okay right so they stayed up all night
lions tigers bears um to
molesters totally yeah and then they
bred with each other and the these are
the people that thrive at night
yes the people that like it at 2 a.m
you're like i'm my most creative
and so you would need it to wind down
the weed to wipe down yes but i was also
in yes yes i said um i i remember like
as a kid and the flight attendant
i i know kaley coco was on the podcast
i'm not like push getting paid to say
this like
the ancestral trauma and the alcoholism
of all that shit really
comes through in the show the flight
attendant because i remember drinking
nyquil
as like a kid right and being like
just trying to like just trying to
fucking
shut it off cunk out yeah
i remember it and then i remember the
coffee and then i remember
and i remember i remember um you know
people think i'm so crazy
uh my mom driving me to work
instead of school you know that hungover
and then i'm in a mall
and i'm in christmas land because she
worked with
you know we worked in malls and so i'm
like
skip school my god christmas
and i get to decorate trees instead
why am i talking to geeks because i
asked you i mean like we're still
getting to know each other and like
unappealing things
i have to read your book i i didn't know
it came out the day
of the vegas shooting oh okay
so that's what i was doing that day
wait um that didn't sound right i mean i
was
and you only had one day to write it so
i'm ready
um no i do i knew i need to like that's
i do need to read it because but i feel
like i also yeah i think we just need to
hang out more and i need to get more
stories so i use this time as as a time
to get to know you because
i do have so many questions for you but
i do agree with like the the family
the trauma that is inherited in your dna
from
because i just recently found out that
like suicide is in my family and
my parents have never talked about and i
go okay this would have been nice to
hear
that i'm not alone on this and that
these thoughts aren't coming from
like that i'm just i'm i'm the first
flawed one of our family like that this
is
there's a history of this and i
um and my problem is i wouldn't want
weed to like get me out of it
weed would make me happy immediately so
it would get me out of it in that way
but i wouldn't want to drink i wouldn't
want to sleep i would i when i get
really depressed i start going
i'm right i'm seeing things clearly and
i know the truth
and i don't want to get medicated
because i don't want to live in a world
where i'm lying to myself that things
are good when things are so fucking
bleak
and you really are worthless and you
really should kill yourself and you're
right to think this
don't don't never forget that you know
right now that this is right
and it takes it takes friends being
telling you like you're you sound really
crazy and being worried for you and
i i just got to the point where there's
a little bit of the um
addicted to the attention
from it like i remember when um
someone in my life kept threatening to
kill herself
and i'm like she's just driving over
there after drinking nyquil
to stop her from killing her and then um
georgia my sponsor uh
is like someone who's texting you
they're going to kill themselves
isn't going to kill themselves right
they're going to do it yeah i never did
that
you know so yeah sorry i do no no no but
that is that's
so that's not always the truth so let me
go like that it made me go like
oh so i don't have to go do i go over
there and
you know it's just such a nightmare it's
it's it sucks
when people do like i s i never wanted
to share these thoughts with people
because i
didn't have a plan to kill myself yet
you know like this was always like
eventually i will have to how am i gonna
do it uh and and being really sad about
like the fact that this
seems like a terminal disease like is
eventually is gonna get me
when am i gonna go for it and it's like
i have no plan of doing that but it just
was always felt like oh it was just
imminent and so
i would never tell my friends and then
when i started telling my friends my
thoughts just kind of like putting it
out there a little bit
you killed yourself i would fucking oh
no it would be the it's the
it's the worst thing to do to everyone
in your life you wouldn't do it
for i'm too scared to do it and uh and i
hate to say that like
i'm i'm glad that there's nothing in me
that wants to right now because i'm
medicated
nobody and i want to talk about that
nobody talks about um
how the uh the media now sounds is like
the new
feminism like the word has lost its
value
um but when the media
they're called cluster suicides oh yeah
when the media bourdain and kate spade
um kate's
i know and when they promote and
everybody posts it post it posts it
and then they say horrified you're so
brave it gets glorified
and you go i wanna somber black and
white picture that everyone shares on
instagram
but the thing is you're not you're not
going to be thinking about it
to see those tributes stop posting about
it
yeah i um you're right they it it needs
to not be covered getting likes on
someone who killed themselves yes it's
but that
is um yeah i i lost someone to suicide
when i was
in high school a friend uh shot him so i
think that's why i go to the gun thing
a friend shot himself that and i talked
about that yeah
yeah a little bit here and there and it
was he was someone that wasn't
a close friend and my parents didn't
like know him but i just was
friends with him at school and he killed
himself because he told
he left a note on my best friend since
fourth grade's uh doorstep that he was
killing himself because she didn't love
him he had confessed his love to her i
was in the back seat of the car when he
did it three days pri two days prior
and i was just giggling in the back seat
like oh my god he's like confessing his
love and she's like i just don't feel
the same way and we went to my house and
we're like oh my god what's he going to
leave in your locker on monday because
he would always confess his love she'd
be like i just want to be friends that
he'd do
seniors in high school and um and then
he didn't come to school that monday and
he shot himself with a rifle that he had
showed us um
that he got for his birthday to go
hunting a couple days before and it was
just
and the the thing with that was i
this is what bugs me more than anything
and i'm attracted to people
who recreate this for me but i was not
allowed to be sad about his death
because my parents were like you didn't
know him like what are you sad about
when i get sad about celebrities death
that i don't know just having boyfriends
being like are you
are you really upset right now are you
crying and then i go like oh i shouldn't
feel sad so i have
really a hard time feeling sad and
crying i like
i can't do it honestly if you had a dog
die
i mean family dogs but not a personal
dog yet no yeah you'll cry
yeah yeah no that's how you cry
i can't remember but you know i probably
uh when i wasn't had to see me
cry yeah benton had to see me cry after
i
we all have we follow your stories
i've been unmuted by nikki glazer oh
yeah
i've been unmuted because now when i see
you i honestly like smile because i'm
like
i don't know i love you so it brings me
joy it doesn't cause me to go oh my god
i need to be doing this i mean there's a
couple things
you do like giving gifts decorating
having renovations just like being busy
just like working and like
providing for people and being friends
with everyone i'm like when does this
girl have time and now it makes sense
that you don't really sleep because
it annoys you it doesn't annoy me it
just like makes me feel like god i need
to be doing that like compare and
despair it's just but do you think i'm
like manipulative no
or like my motives are sticky
no i mean like maybe you want to be
i'm i'm guessing you are someone who
wants to be liked by people and and
i don't want to have the family i never
got yeah that makes sense i just want
sisters
yeah i want to be your sister like it
feels really good to be in the in the
mix like i
i get that it's hard to get you to think
i know it is i really feel like i have
had to work really hard to get you
it's been really i've needed you to to
really
be over the top with it and no yeah
that's what i need so that's really
works
playing easy to get no thank you for
doing that it makes me feel really good
and that's the only way to get me out
and doing things but
i yeah that makes sense to me but i
think i used to really
like but i think
i used to like not like you be and be
jealous of you
because of how hard working you were and
it was all my because i
i wanna i'm sorry because i wanted
i think i keep thinking you're
comforting me or like when you need to
connect with me and then you're like
just stop with the table tapping i could
never
stop like the misophonia stuff oh no
i'm silencing a woman right now that's
what i'm doing
she's talking with her hands body
language is way more important than
verbal language and i'm excited i'll
never hit this table again
knock on wood and then i do it and then
bent like bitch i will pull up all the
clips of you
no i'm sorry you'll have to remind me
again but if it gets you to touch it
it's like when rogan's into it
oh yeah your phone up and i'm like since
when am i shy
um yeah i just i used to resent you
there yeah i you totally my god
i'm sorry i would stop that no i do
because that's me that is who you are
i was annoying though i i i know i'm
triggering
i know but it's because you're really
pretty and really
good at what you do and really hard
working and i know you hate that but
like you are there's just no doubt about
it but
and you're just super talented and so
smart god the words you use i'm like god
i gotta start
because that was a word i only got smart
because i was insecure that i wasn't
smart i would yeah
no that's not why we do everything i
would read dictionaries
and memorize words because i didn't have
any friends you got good words i didn't
have any friends
yeah so i'd read dictionaries i used to
make up um
uh fake identities like this is how i
started writing
i would write i would interview people
in journals of myself
and like name myself tropical lake
and like shit like that and let your
hair color talk to my side
no this is more like moldy
it's so good i love that you haven't
stopped with the hair color and i love
that people are mad at me and they're
like
did you see i i i mean i've been
canceled so many times
you have not i know but it was like i
um posted a tweet that was like
what was it which one
what a saturday
it was a saturday i was like just like
no one
is on twitter on saturday twitter's for
politics and i was like oh
it's amazing how hollywood celebrities
telling everyone to stay home unless
you're like a whole foods worker
or a postmates uh or a nanny starbucks
starbucks
free stuff stay home stay home and then
um
everyone was like but what about whitney
and her influencer parties
like or something and yeah not everyone
it was one person one per
exactly but that's it that's everyone
should be very clear
every one i always have to ask that too
when people go
and then everyone's saying this no
generalizing that's my
i know it is number one new year's
resolutions how do you choose your words
okay i used yeah i used to
have a lot of feelings about you but um
and they're all
like everything that i've that i didn't
like about you is all true i mean it's
it's you're just you're extraordinary
but it's
comes from but now i'm like no you're
actually really
you're just so you're really genuinely
nice and you're honest and
i really just like how you've been like
open about
who you have been how you're just aware
of yourself in a way that's really
refreshing
sleep sleep sleep
sleep people love it and calm can help
you have
it they can
but listen if you're not getting a solid
snipe sleep and you're often find
yourself scrolling through social media
and reading news
and not powering down at night you might
really enjoy calm which is a fun app
with a partner with celebrities and
other noises
celebrities and noises and other noises
i'm calling them noises
and they will tell you stories read you
nice things calm 85 million people
around the world use comm to take care
of their minds to get better sleep
i use it why haven't they asked me you
have a science infection
i have vocal fry they have stephen fry
kelly roland yeah
talking you to bed they read you stories
sleep stories oh my god this is so
amazing it's like asmr sleep time it's
really what it is like celebrities
telling you stories
to help you fall asleep oh my god
i don't have a soothing voice do i or
maybe when you did the bungabunga thing
it was really soothing i thought
maybe i'm not a celebrity or maybe you
can't sleep
i don't think people associate me with
calming
or maybe not how do i make this ad about
me maybe
i'm not yeah not you okay um listen
get the comment it is a really i i've
had it for a while i subscribed to it
calm app this is amazing people telling
you stories to help you fall asleep yeah
you can go to combat.com
whitney you'll get the best voice a
limited time kathleen turner
i do not know her name and that's going
to upset you but the girl
in penny dreadful whoever played the
lead in penny dreadful
i love her voice and she does a calm you
know who i like is um
uh the girl from
oh cazzy david on our podcast
yeah her voice everyone was like her
voice is very soothing
yeah yeah that is true actually scarlett
johansson voice
yeah lots of good voices i get that
for listeners of the show com is
offering a special limited time
promotion of 40 off a calm
premium subscription i wish i would have
got that calm down at com.com
you need to calm the that's held down
forty percent off unlimited this is too
exciting
are you not excited by this no i'm calm
well i'm excited that's forty percent
off unlimited access to comms entire
library and new content that is added
every week
get started today at com.com whitney
that's right it's tricky
called.com that's tricky whitney it's
crazy.com.com.com.com
calm.com that's a tongue twister
whitney i don't know a lot about um
wine i do but i think it's very fancy
when people know about alcohol in like a
chic way and not like in a i'm a drunk
way
yeah and i think that's really cool and
bright cellars did
seven question quiz which i which we
took and it pairs you with what they
think you would like based on like
other things in life you like like what
kind of chocolate you like what kind of
fruits
why are we pretending that we all know
about wine like
just surrender yeah we don't know but
stop acting i learned a lot about wine
you don't
don't don't let people make you feel
stupid because you don't know what a
nutty leafy undertone means like we all
have different tastes
yeah but unless you have kova didn't
have no taste but
like why are we all plum everything
tastes different to different people all
the time but brian sellers will tell you
that they give you a card with each wine
and it gives you the notes in it and it
tells you what temperature they should
be it tells you how to store them
and then you can like kind of once they
kind of describe to you what to be
looking for you can kind of taste the
things it's really interesting also i
just got these shark wine glasses
ordered them for a man that i thought i
was gonna date and he goes to me
but what you saw last christmas as well
not the man
i order them every year and then my
friend nick breaks them every year so i
have to reorder them
they are very um flimsy put your bright
cellars wine
in your shark glass yes make sure you
subscribe to brian sellers wine
is about them uh i'm just saying i just
want you to know i'm
i'm serious when you when you learn
about wine you want to have a good glass
of drink it is
it makes the experience better you think
don't drink it from the bottle like i
did
for good for you listeners get a breast
fed to you like i did
for good for you listeners only we are
giving you 50 off your first six bottle
order from bright sellers
by going to brightsellers.com good for
you that's bright sellers
c-e-l-l-a-r-s dot com slash good for you
you can take their seven question quiz
to get your wine matches and receive 50
off your first
six bottle order have you um
done your ancestry no you gotta
i think my dad did and i like what's
your like what's your
ancestral trauma missouri i don't know i
but we moved there from cincinnati
there's a lot to unpack there well
alcoholism is
the main component of my family as as
and and i guess
depression suicide schizophrenia is in
the but there's a there's a ton of stuff
and i am so i'm so grateful for all of
it but the yeah the suicide thing
is i get the glorification of it when i
get really depressed i like to look up
stories of people who have done it
because i'm like
how did they do it and like you know
it's not even about how they did it it's
you just want to find someone who's as
sad as you and who actually sees the
world like you
saw it and like i have my favorite
podcast about like suicide that i go
back and listen to and i'm really
depressed
it's been months since i've been in that
state of mind
and thankful i mean i was just ready to
go to a hospital or something i was like
oh
you know i need to go away because i
don't wanna
i'm not i have no plan to hurt myself i
was not in that point of it but i was
just like i can't get out of this
feeling and i know there's help
somewhere so i i people just started
telling me i was probably
that my depression could be from add did
you see um
maria bamford's uh special on that
i know her story but i didn't see her
special on it or there's a
maria i know she was hospitalized yeah
she her
she was like i don't want to fuck it up
um let's just put it in
um where she said like my brain's
telling me to kill myself
i need to go to a facility yeah she
checked herself and i think i
that's so cool that she was out about
that and that's what stuff like that
people like that sharing it because you
think if i admit that i want
i've wanted to kill myself on rogan or
like what
on here and and some producers see that
like people don't want to work with
someone who might kill themselves and
it's like
i always have to i always worry like
that's a liability being
suicidal but i think but what is what is
the definition of it
it's like i've i mean we've all had
there are times where i
i remember um there's times where i i
you know bent and saw me after i saw my
mom
when i was every thanksgiving is brutal
all the ancestral trauma comes up and i
see my mom
and she does it always hurts it always
hurts
yeah you know um and i'm never gonna get
her and that's it that's the way it is
and uh i mean i was sobbing
i had to pull over he pulled over two or
three times i had to pull over two or
three times to just like ball
like that that deep like bone crying
like that body that keeps the score read
the book
um and that like heaving crying where
you're like
rocking yeah it's like cartoon and it's
almost like
you you're like you've seen it in a
movie so you're kind of doing it yeah
yeah
yeah you start to feel like am i am i
acting right now
it feels right it's really important to
note though that when whitney is sad it
looks like sadness and yes
that's and so i think people get really
confused i'm like well you're not
depressed you're this or you're that and
it's like
well i mean that's what it looks like it
should look like that's what it should
look like
yes we i mean that is that to me is like
so healthy that you could sob and like
feel those feelings almost immediately
and have to pull over three times
that it sounds terrible i'm so sorry
that no it makes you feel that way but
like
that is a healthy expression of sadness
whereas with depression it goes
we just go inward and hate our it all
that all the sadness goes in and it just
um
yeah it's it it sucks but i have service
service service service so then it's
like okay
now do i decorate my all my fucking
trees yeah
and then i instantly started ordering a
billion ornaments on etsy
and i was like all my friends are gonna
come over and they're bringing their
kids and i'm gonna make a winter
wonderland in my backyard and we're
gonna take photos and we're gonna
fucking fix this
yeah you know it's like how action
transmute that
you know that was the word you used
before that i was like that's a good one
transmutable yeah it's a good one
sublimate is a good one um yes when you
uh take something uh like some of your
pain
and use it in your stand up and
sublimate that pain from my childhood
into my art like
make it useful finally that's what we're
all doing we're sublimating our
my thing right now is just like let's
stop complaining
yeah and start transmuting like how do
we make it work for us
how do we make all this shit benefit us
yeah which i mean yeah no and it has
benefited us
i mean you this you wouldn't be this way
without all this
stuff so i said to you i was like why
haven't you done the 12-step
the aca adult child of alcoholic 12
steps right so for alcoholism to be
present
alcohol doesn't have to be present no
wonder my talk show was canceled
um i can't talk
i can only do stand up where i can
practice for a year
yeah i mean like no one knows that i
have this like secret like
tongue that doesn't fit in my mouth um
these are characteristics we seem to
have in common due to being brought up
in an alcoholic household
alcoholism can be sewing
cooking controlling perfectionism
plastic surgery pot hair dying
pot shopping addiction organizing
anything
that make that your parent did that made
them tuned
out for you and even the big thing i had
was like i have
i had a a close relative who does
who drinks and um but they wouldn't do
it all the time it wasn't a chronic it
wasn't all the time it was just certain
times
what you saw but i saw it and
when they're not drinking they're
thinking about drink it's almost worse
because they're like they're they want
you know you're an obstacle to their
drinking you know they're talking to you
they're zoned out when i when i'm you
know when i'm starving myself all i
thought about was eating i wasn't
connected to anyone i was obsessed with
food you know so
you can't be present even if you're not
or when i was a uh
drinking like oh yeah and a drunk i was
just
if i was sober but it wasn't intoxicated
i was thinking about when can i get
and where am i going to get it and where
is it beer
like i mean i think yeah i mean vodka
soda so it'd be like less calories
because that was like mixing addiction
yeah i was gonna say like i never
became i never drank because i was
anorexic yeah
that was like my thing it was like wine
has too many calories uh-huh
but we had in my fridge growing up and
think think about your fridge growing up
think about it like figure i sit down
look at your fridge growing up
my fridge growing up it was like
two artichokes for guests
we ate artichokes and uh
fucking pinot grigio oh wow and like
cheese for guests
and there was snacking and that was it
and coffee diet coke
yeah like i grew up on thinking that was
normal and then i went to a friend's
house and opened the fridge at like
seven i was like what's all this
juice you know it was like that
chappelle's sketch which
down now um okay these are
characteristics
we seem to have in common uh bringing up
an alcoholic household that is not
out for alcohol to be present alcoholism
to be present alcohol doesn't have to be
present
right now it's happening you're looking
at me control
perfectionism one we became isolated and
afraid of people and authority figures
we became approval seekers and lost our
identity in the process
we are frightened by angry people and
any personal criticism
we either become alcoholics marry them
or both or find
another compulsive personality such as a
workaholic to fulfill our sick
abandonment needs
we live life from the viewpoint of
victims and are attracted by
that weakness in our love and friendship
relationships
i'm like panicking like as if i'm in a
meeting reading like i got chose to read
and i can't do it isn't it wild that all
these things like you're just like
how do the all these things come from
this what i know most of i read this
list i was just like
i'm i finally know what i am by the way
the new alcoholism cell phones
and computers oh god kids kids kids are
like
mommy why are you on that holding that
box totally in front of my face all day
i mean even my mom i'm still i'm
triggered by her
uh obsession with her phone like i just
i feel it's
it it it makes me feel i know ben i do
with benjamin all the time like what are
you doing are you texting what are you
doing
yeah you're doing i constantly feel
abandoned and rejected
i try to put it i've been a lot better
with the phone thing but
yeah that's a complete addiction you got
to be addicted to yours aren't you we
have an
over-developed sense of responsibility
and it is easier for us to look uh for
us
to be concerned with others rather than
ourselves
this enables us to not look too closely
at our own faults
we get guilt feelings when we stand up
for ourselves
instead of giving in to others we became
addicted to excitement
we confuse love and pity
and we tend to quote love people we can
quote
pity and rescue we have stuffed our
feelings from our traumatic childhoods
and have
lost the ability to feel or express our
feelings because it hurts too much this
is called denial
we judge ourselves harshly and have very
low
sense of self-esteem what
we are dependent personalities who are
terrified of abandonment and will
do anything to hold on to our
relationship in order to not experience
painful abandonment feelings which we
received from living with sick
people who were never there emotionally
for us which they couldn't have been
because they were in coal mines and
drinking
and didn't have antibiotics so poor them
what else would they we did the best we
could with the tools we had yeah
forgive them all forgive our parents
alcoholism is a family disease and we
became
para-alcoholics and took on the
characteristics of that disease even
though we didn't pick up a drink
so even if you're not you know
we're reactors other uh rather than
actors
i feel like there's a couple things that
we should like start talking about and a
couple things we should like stop
talking about okay
should i mean there's a couple things i
want to stop talking about okay
like so let's talk about not talking
about them i think that like
me and the eating disorder stuff like i
i we were texting earlier and i was like
i'm done talking about it okay and
you're like but i just started
yeah and i'm like but i did that so this
but this is your show so
we're we're not going to talk about it
no i i think it's important because
you'll uh i can be of service to you and
you can talk about
your shit if you want to yeah i mean i
just the thing that
blew me away that i never thought i
would i just don't skip meals
ever yep and that was the game changer
it was as simple as that because i was a
binge eater i would starve all day
uh binge at night every single night
and um i wasn't garbage i mean i was
like 12 boxes of cereal and protein bars
yeah i can't have cereal in the house
like
cereal i mean i can now because i but
cereal by the way
ice cream um protein bars uh
loca like those um sugar sugar low sugar
gummy bears oh god those are the but
this is what i've done
oh disgusting i know just dieting stuff
stuff that doesn't
froyo the sugar-free froyo yeah the real
big
right how does that fill it with that if
you just start eating like a normal
person
and don't skip them as a normal person
okay eat
um i want to be careful and i'm going to
be a bully about it
sure just use words like benj and i
talked about um
instead of saying that's not healthy you
say that's not helpful oh
yeah yeah you know like to not
pathologize
don't bully ourselves no i that's that's
a real
big thing for me i don't want to be hard
on myself about any of this stuff but
we're also fucking comics it will be
funny
when i say normal eat like just having
meals that
people don't go what are you eating like
that like that's not my whole life
barbecue
sauce on carrots just yes yes
yeah so i and it's also we can also say
disordered eating
that's another thing yeah i just that
has changed
everything is um the fact that i just
never trusted myself to eat meals that
other people
that i'd see other people eat because i
was like i can't i always have to have
less because i'm
different and it's going to do something
different completely special
i'm different yeah i can't have that i
have to have lesson um
and i always thought and i was always so
hungry that i didn't trust myself to
have normal meals because they go oh if
i have a normal meal then i won't be
able to stop
but it was because i was fucking
starving that's why i couldn't stop
and um and i just had to like trust and
that's
i think that's just what i like to like
get out there is that i just never
this intermittent fasting bullshit
please like
just be careful because it's well
everything it's like i just feel like a
lot of these diets are excused to have
an eating disorder it's like
this and the keto and the paleo and the
vegan and the it's like everyone's just
like
needs it it's the the ultimate addiction
is control
at the end of the day like when you go
home and you're like i'm vegan
you know there's an amazing book that i
have to find the name of about how
in italy um the
families were uh breaking apart in a
very real way
um you know food is such a big part of
how
the mothers show loved their children
right and after
american television came in hashtag
silvio berlusconi hosted the podcast
bunga bunga
now on apple podca i don't even know um
uh that they
not eating anything with milk or dairy
or not wanting carbs
they're rejecting their mother's love
really tearing
apart these italian families like it's
like if some if your mother serves you
makes you food that she made pasta and
you don't eat it
yeah it's a rejection of her we got a
problem yeah
well and when you when you do have those
restrictions on your life i mean
that's why i didn't go on dates i didn't
like i would oh that's a meal i have to
not
skip bummer fuck i know it's exhausting
right before because oh i have to have a
lunch with this producer
fuck okay well i guess i can't binge
tonight waste of your life for
it's just so much energy goes into like
planning
when you can eat when you're it's just
absolutely you are not put on this
planet to spend the whole time
i'm so much happier just not being able
to let a little bit of that go and it's
what would you say is the main thing
that helped you like
it was it was not skipping a meal not
letting myself do that yeah i don't get
to do that like that
having a firm rule because i'm as
anorexic i'm great at following rules
and so now i've set this rule for myself
and i cannot break it so i have to eat
bottom lines right
yeah i have bottom lines yeah just like
i do not skip a meal
and i don't chew gum why oh man i'm i'm
a gum addict
i was like it's like i'm up to two packs
instead of
instead of eating eating a diet soda
yeah i'm wearing coffees now you know
and then when everybody
i got someone got mad at me uh uh about
um someone sorry i'm generalizing the
thing i'm not doing
because i said don't do anything you
don't want to do to allison bray oh yeah
i liked that
like don't do anything you don't want to
do ever and it's like and people are
like you don't have good manners and
you're this it's like no i just
i've abused myself for so long
and i'm so sorry to my body
that when i put it through i'm so like
grateful that it like stuck with me
yes that i am just trying to
make up for lost time with like baths
and lotions and oils and good
food and olive oil
and the you know like i'm just trying to
and yeah and
and relaxation and not i mean but you
never stop but that's do you just not
need to sleep see yeah
okay so i remember hearing a rumor about
you that you like
you're like jay leno like you only need
like three hours of sleep to function
like you're just not like us
that's not true at all i remember
hearing like whitney has the thing where
it's like you
you're genetically you have a genetic
mutation that makes you only need three
hours of sleep who told you that
i don't remember um probably just some
catty circle of female comics
um okay so you do sleep yeah okay
it's the biggest priority of my life
it's awesome i love sleep so much
invented explained my sleep she sleeps
like a normal person eight hours
um yeah yeah shakes naps too yeah
and if she doesn't then we don't do
anything
yes they come first and
what's your relationship with um oh god
what was i just gonna oh
um oh shit what was it
no let me think because it was it was
good oh you know what's your
relationship with doing
things that might not contribute to
to work might not might not hobbies
healthy hobbies healthy hobbies there we
go
so that's my thing with a lot of the
people in
my life that i've seen during this
quarantine
kind of crumble is like what are your
non-work related hobbies
what are your i used to have none
uh what are you doing for fun and for
free
that is just for play just for your
inner child
i remember going to my sponsor 12 years
george davis i mean she was on the
podcast i think during quarantine to
kind of talk about the whole like
how traumatizing all of the words the
media was using
of like shelter in place like these are
words that were used for like
hunker down these are words that were
used in war
like this is not words we should be
using so i go into georgia and i'm like
mom me me me and all my problems all my
problems that i'm so what my life is so
hard and this and sexual abuse
and this and narcissists and alcoholism
my life has been so hard
and she's like okay so and i work so
hard and i'm just slammed
i'm the busiest person on the planet and
i'm texting and she's like so what are
your hobbies and i was like
well i like write shows and i'm writing
a book
and i'm like yeah you know and she's
like no what did like what do you do
like for fun
horses i'll go well that was this was 10
years ago
oh gotcha and then i was like so i um
no i like hanging out with friends like
i have this friend that i'm writing a
script with and
everything was work and al-anons we tend
to
any time we have a hobby we turn it into
a job so or
into a business like right away so it's
like i'm going to start making quilts
it's like
oh i should do this for my friend's new
baby now i need to put this on etsy now
when you started business you suck the
fun out of it by making by monetizing it
and by making it yeah
it's no fun you gotta put on instagram
now it has to be you know
so i have uh now my bottom line uh
is four hours a week uh two hours
two separate days um non-work related
hobbies
where i can't post interesting
so i'll do it i'll post with my horse
after we've done our two hours
and then i'll post because people really
like i mean people yeah i've got people
i'm generalizing people probably think
i'm fucking nuts
uh uh what's new and
but i have to do no phone with the horse
i have to look at the phone in case i
have a dog emergency but
i have like really strong boundaries
about play and i do adult coloring books
you do they're awesome i'll give you one
you
that's i've heard that those work
they're so soothing
do you like but do you like think of
ideas for jokes and stuff like i've
heard that they're good to like
yeah it starts to because i meditation i
we're we're not
i just i'm big on leaning into your
um uh the crazy things about you like
are your superpowers
like your ocds you're this you're like
how do you make them work for you
yeah everyone else is pathologizing you
and telling you that you're crazy but
like
i have all these superpowers that you're
trying to tell me are bad what was the
word mutinized mutation transmission
transmute yeah
mutinize mutant type immunity
transmute i can remember that trans
transmute
mute like trans like the
the the
so everyone's like whitney's so generous
it's like yeah but this is
for me also yeah you know so it's like
what are your motives
i'm going to give you all this shit yeah
and i'm going to do all this for you and
i want to do all this
but it's like it's for me also yeah
because i get to stop thinking about
myself for five fucking minutes
oh that's it yeah thank you for letting
me not think about myself for five
minutes
i remember my my ear got bitten off um
oh yeah a friend of mine came and i was
like
and i just happened to she's like the
only she's famous so it's like the only
i was in the waiting room and i was like
asked someone and we didn't even speak
the same language like
look up this person and dm her from me
and like i dm'd her assistant
from because i ended up my phone and she
came and she's programmed
and my ears bleeding and she's helping
me and she
was like thank you so much for letting
me be of service oh
you know it was like thank you so much
for calling me yeah i got to not think
about myself for two hours yeah and it's
hard to ask people for help like i i
have a hard time accepting but it's
enough for people
it's over it's over yeah 20 21 remember
when your ear got bitten i remember i
was like i want my hair to get
like it was there was a little bit of
like school like everything she does is
cool like
pink i think i literally was jealous
when your ear got bitten off
it's a little flashy it's a little splat
it's like when my um
uh nude uh boob got leaked and
uh i don't know who it was maybe schultz
or someone was like wasn't that planned
i was like
what i was like i wish i was that how
did that happen
i'm talking about in my next special
okay okay we'll see it if we ever get to
do specials again
yeah um well but like
like let's hit some boundaries for like
i wasn't the only one who saw your
boobs you've seen my boobs everyone yeah
i mean today was the first time
yeah i also yeah i talked they were
crooked and they were i feel like
they're a
thing do you think they are what are
some what do you how do you think you're
perceived
um oh god i hate i hate to even
answer that um that's what we do here i
really don't want to even
know how i am i hate when people do
impressions of me
um a whale
whales i love whales so much oh my god
these are so cool i'll seriously wear
these i love whales i used to be so
obsessed with whales as a kid
why did you bring them that's so crazy
that they were here yeah i mean whales
are whales are my um they're the goat
of animals and the goat is also a goat
but it's why do you love whales
big blue whales they're what are like
huge adjectives
to describe a whale mysterious
uh um gigantic
and gentle okay
what is that does that mean that those
are things i think about myself
or that i want to be no okay i'll let
you know all right
yeah i love whales and i think i'm
perceived as
someone who talks about sex a lot and
someone who um my next person is very
just honest
and like just uh over shares um
verbal diarrhea and you haven't said
funny yet
no i mean i i think yeah i think people
think i'm funny but i guess i don't
think i'm funny
so i don't want to say that because i'm
like oh if people say if i say
funny then people will be like no you're
not and i'm like don't want to hear that
so
but you're but the but you have the
apartment that is paid for by the i
trick
i don't know how i tricked someone into
yeah it's
it's so crazy it's and that's so so your
audience is stupid
so you're calling your audience it's
ridic there no
i mean you know the do you ever feel
like you're the funniest person in the
world after a set and then another set
later you're like i
am a joke and i've never been funny in
my life like i vacillate so i do have
confidence about it i do know that i'm
funny but you know i i um everyone's
funny first of all
yeah everyone's i agree so just because
everyone's funny
then i am fine then you're funny okay
like memes have taught us all
i know there's some that i'm like geez i
know that's
some random why didn't a woman that
works at chipotle
in fact clearwater florida makes this
banger meme and i'm like jesus the
comments
on no one talks people want to talk
about negative comments i will not talk
about them anymore
no one talks about how fucking funny
comments are i'll do a caption
funny killing crushing oh i mean i get
jealous
of people i'm like easy this is okay
okay you're high
i'm the one you know it's wild people
are so funny people are
so funny so that's why i feel like bad
even though yes i am a comedian i am
funny i i know i'm funny i just
but imagine like having a nail salon
and being like i'm bad at nails i know i
know
horrible nails it's it's
i just i don't know i'm not as funny as
i wanna be like what would your
storefront be
if you were like nikki glazer's comedy
um
i don't know just like uh just things
other people won't say yeah stu like
things like i remember i
said something on stage once and this
woman goes
i forget it was like like talking about
the taste of calm or something like that
and this girl was like
ugh and i was like oh you've never
tasted like you've never tasted cup she
goes
i mean i have i just wouldn't admit it
on stage
that is yeah that's why i'm getting paid
that's my
plane flew me here yeah and i we are
paid really for our bravery yeah yeah
i mean i think so and then i've found a
way to
and i study comedy and i've like learned
how to be
really funny and i am naturally funny
it's naturally funny but funny is not
it's like it's
balls yes i think the balls to say the
thing
and thank god i don't have a filter i
mean
but i do think that part of this is
why you're you know it's like the reason
you're so funny is the reason you don't
think you're funny so it's like also our
yes never feeling like enough and having
anyone that comes on stage was like
nailed it you're like i know easy buddy
easy buddy yeah i i i felt that way
before but i don't say
it a surgeon doesn't leave surgery and
he's like
they it's so weird yeah i mean like i
there are times though that i feel like
wow i really nailed that i i just
i'd never want to um i i
sometimes just feel bad that people have
paid so much money and i'm like
we need to get into your regal we need
to get into your pride and regal
you need to get some horses and some
dogs and train them okay
no one wants you to be um apologetic
yeah no one needs it no no no they don't
pay for it no they i know right
and then but that's why i don't read
like any comments because i'm so scared
i'm gonna
hear these sentiments echoed um and
someone's like
noticed them and uh and been like yeah
you
you you are a fraud you know like all
that shit but actually i don't
i've i've let a lot of this go like i
feel like the pandemic has really helped
me center and be like what's really
like what is important i know that's
like so cliche to say but i really
just want like good friends and good in
my family to be hitting
the fucking scene sorry i just want to
be happy
i just want to not one that's it that's
it i just want to not feel bad about
myself and that is my resolution is to
just
be so nice to myself like
anything i used to beat up myself about
no no more no more you don't have to be
perfect
you don't even have to try there's no
goal the new resolution new year's
resolution
is no near new year's resolution nothing
that you can fail at and get mad at
yourself about
never anything anything i'm
i'm tired of being i've been so mean to
myself my whole life i know
no more it's enough like you're dope and
you're hot and you're smart
just be like okay don't say flaw say
superpower
last night i was picking out my hangnail
and i really was talking to myself and i
was like stop doing this you know it's
going to bleed and you know it's going
to make a big well you need to get the
cuticle cutters
i have everything i i'm not kidding you
i like i have the tools i know what i
use no but this is all but the female
brain sorry sorry
watch it dude this is that is all very
primal
biological there's a biological basis
for all of that
yeah and but my my point being is that i
just
no more trying not to ever have any
negative self just being like oh it's
okay girl
and those voices you can just um
personify them and be like oh that was
weird thought
yeah i have a russian gymnastics coach
in my head and he
is um he's being furloughed right now
he'll be back he's still we still zoom
sometimes
do you are you have russian ancestry no
but it's just like i have a bella
corolla really yeah
where's dave kelly eve um
love god i can't just her
okay obsessed space it can't be real
it's so good it's very similar to your
real yeah it's
it's good she's yeah they're just like
the the tiny micro
movements of she's so good she's beyond
yeah that was the first
that was the first time in a really long
time i was like
i i might be bisexual like
this is i'm the i'm i don't believe i
was like my parents
i was like i was like i get it yeah
no i was i really for the first time
really felt like this isn't just a girl
crush this isn't like a haha
i
i just want to be with her yeah it has
to be her
yeah that's like me with babies i'm like
i don't know if i want a kid i want that
kid
yeah i want that exactly yes yes
that's how i felt about that but you
know what you never told me what you're
on
oh i'm on um uh i don't want to say what
i'm on because then people like are just
going to like do it and it
works different it's different for
everyone yeah so i'm on but i'm on an
antidepressant and a med for adhd
and i have not had a suicidal thought
since the day i started taking the adhd
medication you are literally like
on a different like i'm calmer
you're me calmer when i i feel like
we're like on a
laughed yeah i felt really soothed like
we're at fucking asmr
yeah we're at like a club med sandals
resort
connected and what is your favorite
article of clothing
oh as soon as you said that i just
thought about this like sweater that my
mom got me from h
m that i always get compliments on and i
love being like it was ten dollars at h
m and i know that because my mom told me
that's
i hate when you're like what's that
sweater agent everyone's gotta tell you
everyone how little they spent on their
shirt yes yes cozy
cozy big oversized what like how would
you describe a friend's sweater i have a
someone loved me once or i had a mom who
got was on
shopping the sale rack at h m christmas
eve what are the um
characteristics to characteristics to
describe it um
bit oversized gigantic again big
um uh
just um cute
versatile instead of cute and um
uh like just
um and will last forever like is it
timeless
ooh is it like an off-the-shoulder
situation
it's like a cozy like it's almost this
color
beige just like cozy just you can wrap
it in like almost a blanket
of a of a cardigan
wow interesting um and then
do you made by children huh made by
children overseas
made by slave labor i forgot to say that
the blood oh yeah that's all of the
indian children yeah
um and then what are you a water person
yeah yeah really i was a swimmer you're
like a lake person
no no i don't want to like do things on
the water i
i don't want to go on a boat i don't
want to like have adventures i'm not
outdoorsy
but i do i used to loves i am like
that's like
was my sport and i'm i'm like i can swim
and stuff and i love scuba diving but no
i don't want to like have it
i i really like it because scuba diving
was the first time that i was really
the second time i did it i was really
able to be present because of the
breathing
yes the first time you i to make
yourself go down yeah
the first time i was like oh that's what
breathing is yes that's all you can hear
down there and it's all the the only
thing you can focus on
because i have so much breathing shit
from when you grow up in a catacomb you
hold your breath a lot because you try
to be quiet and hide it's from hiding
and the way women carry our purses
we hunch and constrict our
um uh chest cavity
and i got surgeries on my move so it's
all
like and stand up is
i got to hold my breath because i got to
say this
yeah i'm always holding my mind you know
what i mean always hold him right i hold
my breath when i take pictures
oh that's interesting everybody takes a
picture i'm like
take it cuz you're sucking in i don't
know i'm like doing a giant kegel
yeah and then i'm like dizzy and i don't
know we hold our breaths a lot
yes yes we don't even know it but scuba
diving
is like it's just transcendent it was
like so much it's a lot of rigor
role yeah it is it's a lot oh man i've
only been i don't know i don't want to
pretend like i do this all the time
king and scuba diving once every 10
years like you're trying to get
uh both of those things friend like me
like trying to get like that's
what i've done it's like it's like
trying to get some rich guy
like i'm like i guess i scuba dive now i
do this and i'm this oh all the things
i've pretended to be into
tell me all of them no more hiking no
more hiking
listen how about i broke my shoulder uh
snowboarding
trying to get a guy like me yeah no i
definitely like um
yeah i've done that where you just like
morph into the version of the girl that
you think they're gonna
love eating like in a cheerleading
uniform
but i actively like on dating apps if
someone's like has a lot of
outdoor pictures a lot of like on the on
the lake
or like just likes likes doing
things anything outdoor like i just go
out to like do something out of your
comfort zone because you love someone
yeah
like people try to comfort me about this
it's like you're allowed to go like i
don't
like hockey i think it's fucking boring
i'm sorry it's
fucking i can't even see the thing like
i don't know if i have like a vision
issue
i'm like a herding dog i'm like an
aussie shepherd like i i just
it's too much movement for me and it's
when you're close
it's it's like i've been sat in the
front front
because i've um made some mistakes and
dated some
athletes and uh and then you sit in the
box in the back and you're like i don't
even what is it
yeah we're eating like now you know and
then you're in the middle
the show it's really more the people
around you that you're like fucking
yes getting the adrenaline from like
being like fuck you man oh this fucking
guy yeah so many sporting events
yeah it's just about that be accepted
yeah but
hockey like so it's like i can go to
hockey with you
just because it's for you i can be of
service but i am not allowed to in six
months ago i went to that fucking hockey
game with you and you can't meet my
friend nikki
yes yes it's not it can't score uh-huh
i love that you said that on the allison
pre-episode where you're like used to
give gifts
with like there was a there's strings
attached like literally i'm sure you
decorated it with strings but like
there was always i'm sure
i mean the gifts you gave me i cannot
this is more than i've gotten in five
years
of christmas there isn't an h m sweater
in there i'm gonna
i mean it like it's it's insane but yeah
i i
i agree with you i i would just i would
just always just try to do whatever a
guy would want me to do and now i
finally know like i don't like
kayaking and canoeing and then and
lamping how about this
and then they think we're a stick in the
mud
because we go and we don't like it yeah
it's like and that's where the
stereotype comes from
being a stick in the mud is triggering
because it's outdoors
and it involves like getting dirty so
it's like for me and then i'm going
i'm doing your thing and i'm trying to
make you like me but i like can't do it
right and i'm not good at it they're
like oh women are weak and women are
stupid and they don't get it it's like
just don't go
hunters and gatherers they just fucking
separated
so now i will go on the things but i'll
be clear about like i don't usually do
this it is not something that i enjoy
but i'm gonna
but sometimes i do enjoy it like i ended
up loving scuba diving i haven't gone
since but like
i did love it sometimes i go on a hike
and i'm like this is the fucking best
but you gotta it's like you trying to
get me to hang out like you gotta force
me to do things but
i i i have i struggle between knowing
when i don't
if i don't wanna do something is it out
of fear or is it out of like i truly
don't like it i don't trust myself but
now i really know i don't like
uh canoeing i don't wanna canoe
i tested it and i go i'm gonna go and
i'm really gonna put this to the test
and so i can forever say i tried it
where did you canoe
i went canoeing with my um my my
brother-in-law like
i don't know what a company point of
canoeing exactly
that is my issue with it too i'm like
what are we but what do we do
hundreds we try to get to the other side
of the line you like see
things that are that's the point like
with hiking you just like see
nature and i guess it's like soothing
and being on the water it's calming but
it's like
a lot of work and your back hurts and
you're wet you're like you have to
change your tampon yeah and like your
feet are in the boat in there it's like
where's washington
hold your phones in like a ziploc bag
it's it's
it's gonna flip it's not for me so now i
know that but i
i went on a date and the guy took me on
a hike and i was like i gotta be honest
with you i hate i don't
this isn't gonna be something if we work
out like we're gonna be doing together
like this is gonna be your thing but we
went on this hike and at some point
during it
i snapped and i was like i hate this
because if we had to like go through
some
like bro like just a little bit of
foliage we had to like lift a branch and
i was like
oh my hair like i was so scared of my
hair like getting
tangled and ripping out and um and i was
like
i go if i get lyme disease i am sending
you a bill you're paying for
everything i do not want another goddamn
disease that no one believes
i cannot see another celebrity get lyme
disease no you can't i can't do it so i
was like i was really bitching and he i
remember he was very like are you okay
but
i felt good because i was like oh at
least i was honest and like i wasn't
pretending
to like it and you're not lying you mean
and i wasn't like you're not a liar yeah
yes i'm not a liar but i always think
that i'm
wrong and that like my likes and my
dislikes are wrong
and flawed and that i'm weird for my
likes and dislikes so i always
don't want to voice them because i just
hit this
like benton and i were in new york and i
was like i hit this like this
integration
happened where i was like dude all the
things i thought were fucked up by
myself are kind of fucking
awesome yeah i was like oh dude like
like what that like well and also just
like honoring our ancestors and like
i'm like oh shit you're afraid to get
caught in a tree
dude your great great great grandmother
yeah yeah yeah he's probably fucking
like you know a forging bitch
and she like bombed and weaved and like
you got that
imprinted on your dna like the
epigenetic imprinting from that like
that is like your weird things of like i
can't be that like you're like what else
that make everyone kind of go
yes like they're so they're so dope like
i think mine are smart like the things i
don't like i'm like i don't like
two-lane highways
i will not be on them i will never drive
to las vegas
ever again from los angeles i don't like
a highway where people are going over 30
miles an hour and there's only one lane
separating it
it's that that's smart because people
are texting now
you go like this and it's a head-on
collision you have a car accidents in
your
uh no past or no maybe in your answer in
my future
i'm just saying if i do die in a car
accident this will definitely go viral
yeah you've got to post it so
are you just playing mario kart
could someone put a banana in her
stovepipe that's what i was about to say
because there used to be a game i don't
know what it is there used to be a gig
called the stone piper
that i used to do outside
[Applause]
um what are your phobias do you have any
like irrational
fears that make everyone like you have
people kind of have to like cater to
them please
i mean you don't like uh your eye to be
pulled on even though you literally pull
on it every day
okay benton okay so okay when he will do
this skin and pull her skin
but then when you're doing her makeup
she's like don't pull my skin meanwhile
she's like this
no i got my makeup done today and they
have to like lift my you know how like
when you get fingered and a guy has to
like do that to your vagina and like
lifts that kind of like get in
yeah like when i was young they just
like put makeup on now they have to like
search for my cl like they have to peel
it someone has to hold it off
the older you get there's like more skin
to like lift open
and just it's so but i totally get the
skin pulling thing that's why i won't go
skydiving
it's not out of fear of heights i don't
want my face to go like
like i don't want my face to stretch out
and be a baggy sweater
that i do love when i get to the
breakfast
yes you know like that's you have fear
of stretching skin
like making silly faces going like that
i would never do that ever
okay so there is there are about 10
writers in hollywood
that i'm sure have told everybody in
hollywood that i am uh this uh
story or this about me that when i was
in the writers room of a one
nbc whitney i would say to
the writers don't make me laugh because
i don't want to get these laugh lines
and and and then i was like oh that's
obviously ridiculous these are writers
they're they're best joke the best joke
writers
available uh dan levy was there and uh
and i would some would make me laugh and
i would go oh yeah
i don't do this and then i had the
little exerciser thing
that like exercises your muscles uh-huh
uh
it was like a contraption and
um do you sleep on your stomach someone
who doesn't know
always on my back straight up like a um
mummy
you still do that um yes with noise
canceling headphones on
so that the product stays on my face oh
my god
absorbing the pillow and also silk
pillow yeah i do stick pillowcase but
i'm like i'm definitely like ugh
never no no because then before i go if
i ever sit on my side
you lift the skin off yeah i do that and
then yes yes but then
you shift throughout the night oh my god
i brought this i forgot
um i was going to put this in your
package this is a do you have this
a decolletage is it for your for your
tits
for your to put on oh
wait do you wear it like does it get
wrinkles of course oh my god
yes that that that wrinkled chest that
reminds me of
like my ants yeah no i can't do it so
it's gonna happen though
i also um wear gloves in the car i can't
i mean yes
oh i love i love masks because they
cover your sk
like i wear mine in the car before bed
and you do this there they are again
it's a fucking
oh yeah yeah
that's great yeah and then you're
you don't get those chest wrinkles
that's i mean
i'm probably use it one time and then i
won't again but i love that you do this
every single night but you don't stretch
out your face at all you don't like
anything when you're with your dude and
they want to have sex with you you're
like
uh you know i just roll on my stomach
like i don't want them to take off my oh
yeah
my weird scratch and sniff sticker you
put that oh yeah sex starts after yeah
and then it starts to have like weird
hair on it and like lotion
can i have that one yeah do i get that
one has whitney dna on it back
i did a lot of like informal modeling
and like
i grew up around like
forget that you're a yeah well no like
like mall model
like your model like a local model well
you could
you could have kept modeling they you
would have those little tricks
i mean yeah it's it's too much i just
feel so overwhelmed by all the things
don't don't don't stay beautiful stop
that well how do i stop
what are you doing now what is this so
then the
i never apply my creams down so up
always up
up up up you don't go like this with
your cream so you never go like
oh my god your your skin um is like a
rubber band
yes you know what i mean so it's like it
and i said i was
fighting with screaming at tim dillon's
face the other day because it was like
treat your
skin like a piece of leather
not should never be wet too long should
never be in the sun too long
it should never not be lubed up okay
that's what it is
right you know so it's like for me i
um only upward motions for your makeup
or whatever
and then fingers because the brushes i
think are just like scratchy here
and then i do do this to do my eyeliner
yeah but then benton was doing it in
like
circles or something and that's what
okay that's what i mean circles
promote blood flow which promotes the
health of your under eye
attraction not promotion i just
i mean yeah that's that and and there's
a lot of genetics at play
for everybody worse you know and i did
ulthera for
three years i think i'm doing it
tomorrow what is that it's like a laser
that is titans yeah yeah that's ahead of
it
yeah yeah and i'm not the the topical
laser that takes your
layers of skin no good i think because
it thins your skin
long term and gives you more sun damage
okay but this is one that goes that like
your body thinks you're dying and you
gave me so many
serums how many what is your regimen
like how long does it i can't at the end
of the night i mean i'm sure
yeah don't go into deal i know you're
not going to give it away but like how
long does it take you when you go to bed
do you just go
oh good god i gotta start this process
do it while i'm like
facetiming friends okay female comics
um like esther and andy or whatever i'll
just be like doing my thing or i'll be
with my dogs or i'll be watching tv
or i'll be like new face listening to a
podcast i did the new face for a long
time but my derma roller
um we have created an oil
a hoil you created one veggie ray
it was about time hikerson and i have
created a coil
um that will be because i use like five
different oils and i don't want to tell
people to buy five different oils it's
obnoxious and annoying and it's clutter
and i don't really well i don't want
people's house to look like my purse
so i uh we're putting it in it comes out
next year at some point oh my god
give or take give or take it's got to
come out next year
we're also making a beard oil oh
which is a hair i mean it could be for
yeah i have a place i'll use in my hair
too
and uh that has biotin in it so it
promotes hair growth
promotes um but yeah i mean it's just
like you you
people you got sunscreen on the hand
sunscreen on the face like i just
am like a gnarly about it yeah
your hair thing have you gone into depth
about your hair color
like i'm sure that you covered it like i
because i was getting back to it
i i remember when you did it and you
were like i was like there's no way
that's gonna last and it's lasted
i don't know i love it so much i like i
just
i'm sick of like like hollywood i'm i
like doesn't fuck with me in a way
that is like in terms of like casting
like i've always been like
i gotta be there like i'm not getting
those jobs
when you were trying to be what they
wanted so it's like okay
too tall i'm too loud i'm too nasal i'm
too too tall
obnoxious always too tall too loud too
big
too fucking annoying too
this to that like and it just was and i
i kept my hair color brown
just because it was like well what if i
need to audition and what if i might get
this
job for this amazon show or this netflix
show and i just was like
fuck it dude it was just and then the
pandemic happened it was like
you know did you look back at the when
you were like
really like you know during like whitney
times when you were just
operating on a level that was
probably you look back it was like
unhealthy for you and you were not
you were unconscious do you think but
did you think you were happy did you
know you were miserable did you
like i had no concept i was no i was
stoked i grew up poor dude yeah
like having your own i like i don't fuck
with that shit i don't fuck with the
i got everything i wanted and i'm gonna
be miserable i don't do that
yeah anymore it's fucking it's
ungrateful it's rude
like we are nailing like you know what
i'm saying you have to take the wins
when they come
and i was so they just excited that i
got to work with my
fucking best friend and get all these
expensive clothes
that i got to wear and i got to play in
front of it i got to put on a play in
front of a bunch of people
yeah that were like thought it was funny
which is what a play is yes there were
like people there laughing it was a
blast
yeah like and for all the people that
dragged me so hard so publicly for so
long and i was like such a punching bag
i was just like
oh you guys i didn't know about it yeah
it happened like later interesting and i
like googled myself or
like press started coming out and then
it was like oh whitney like cancel
whitney and whitney's like annoying and
dumb and stupid and sexist and
obnoxious and skinny and ugly and
whatever the fuck annoying and not funny
and all these things
and i just was like dude i i just bought
a
home like i grew up poor yeah like what
are you like okay
like i didn't give a fuck it was just
sort of like but so jealous
yeah but i was like yeah i was like
having a
bl i was just like laughing with crystal
no you you
you did look like you were having fun
too and that was infuriating as well i'm
just
i'm sure all of us if i saw a show that
was called like always
you're always having fun but i was alone
for so long
and like um didn't have fun for so long
and i i don't know how to have fun
not working because i'm like i don't
know my role
yeah like going into a party or
something i'm like can i clean up can i
help
i don't know how to just you know
be so but if i know everyone where
everyone's places and everyone's job
okay you're the key girl you're the
lighting person you're
you play my sister in the show and you
play my brother oh my god we did that
shoot the other day
and like you just like
you're you need to fix your hair like
you just like taking care and being like
you'll thank me later
like just oh yeah i mean yeah i mean i
i i needed that because i didn't have a
hair makeup person there
women can handle the truth yes
we have to stop with this like
dad would have hurt her feelings like
shh we could handle it we can have
a we are designed to have something tear
through our bodies
with no anesthesia as you're saying this
i'm like can i handle the truth like
there are times where i'm just like i
would have
maybe rather from the right person not
yes yes and when it's like
said in a way that's like this happens
or by the way
like you're gonna you're not gonna like
this now i don't know but in like two
i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna do that um but in two
years you're gonna go like ah
that was true i remember i had an ex who
uh
was really not well and he said to me
once we were in the car
and we like went to a dinner and i'm a
comic right so it's like i'm like 27
and i'm like fucking fucking always got
the
mitts on i don't know boxing gloves on
they're always like hey this was the
fucking shirt and sweater the fucking
shirt shirt like i just saw i just was
used to being around comics all the time
yeah that's how my family talk to each
other
you know it's like roseanne's family it
was like we just all we did was roast
each other and make fun of each other
and then i went to like a uh
sophisticated
family gathering where people respected
each other you know i'm like
a feral animal and uh i was like boom
boom boom
like killing like meeting his parents
and his parents friends
yes i'm like destroying this dinner
right and then i'm roasting him the guy
i'm with i'm like yeah because he
doesn't fucking do this and he doesn't
forget and he doesn't know how to do
this
and i'm killing yeah and then we get in
the car and he was just like you're a
bully
and i was like what what do you mean
like i was like i thought i knew that
they loved me like i was so funny did he
not know any of the things that you had
said no it was just like all the it was
funny because it was all true
yeah oh yeah so it was hurtful
yeah because it was and i was like oh
i'm being a
bully fuck it was stuff that he's
probably ashamed of and would like to
change about himself
you're humiliating yeah yeah yeah you
can't do that to men
no you can't roast anything they're so
men do not
know a guy that like like is okay
no do not you you can't and it's hard
to not do that because that is what
we're good at
and but i i mean i sometimes i'm like
you know why
haven't these guys i've liked liking me
back or whatever and i go
i don't know that i they don't want to
be made fun they're so scared of us
talking about their penises in our act
and um it's not just stand-ups it's a
people comes we're like no guys
it's all everyone yes everyone's got a
microcosm of it it's like people like is
it hard dating a girl who's
breaking up with someone who's famous
it's like in your town
if you break up with someone you're
they're it's
everyone but if someone dates you
whitney they're gonna get talked about
on here and
for most guys that they don't want that
yeah
and even if you're saying nice things
they don't want like if they do that's a
red flag too
yes so it's like it's it's a hard person
to it's hard to find the right person
um uh okay so the your favorite animal
whale is how you perceive yourself
big mysterious gigantic and gentle
okay yeah and it's a little this one is
this is maybe the weirdest one i've done
and endangered indeed that's why i like
them too they're like the not many of
them
underwater endangered like they're just
so low
they pop up every now and again if you
see one it's very very special and
they're the biggest animal
ever and yeah it's special very special
i love that so i think that that's why i
like them but gentle is good i
really want to be gentle yeah that's how
you see yourself that's good
yeah i want to be gentle and then
uh your favorite article clothing is how
other people perceive you and usually
there's a big dissonance
this is based on a freudian test oh um
oversized gigantic big blanket cute
versatile timeless
hmm okay and then we did get your body
of water
what what is there a sweater that's
funny though is there a way to say that
about it
like you're everyone that's the best
everyone's like she's so great she could
do anything she's so
warm she's cozy timeless
a lot of your like you you should
rewrite your story about yourself
yeah it's like updating your software
yes
you know what i mean it's like no one's
mad at you no i am rewriting that story
about myself i like i'm i'm beginning to
see myself the way others are how are
you doing
great people like the fact that you like
i like you i trust you i trust you to
have good judgment of people if you like
me i'm like okay then i must be good i'm
gonna
put it over and my fans if they think
i'm funny people are stupid i like these
people they're
actually i do like my fans like security
is over it's yeah they're right i'm not
right yeah
my person is not correct you're not one
of your fans you don't go see your shows
yes and i uh i think i probably would
honestly yeah right
i'm trying my favorite body of water um
it could be a pool
it could be a pond it could be a pool it
could be a ripple the time i squirted i
left a puddle in a bed
in las vegas at the win
i was it was the only time i was so
excited i'm not even joking that was
i didn't know i could it was the best
feeling of my life
i was uh and it was just so much and i
remember i immediately like
like went like this to be like is it p
and it wasn't something different and
i've never been able to
recreate it and
that was but if we're talking about like
yeah bodies who at the when
i mean it wasn't it was me by myself
with a yeah you tried to do it what the
only
i know yeah well no i didn't know it was
i didn't i thought i couldn't score it i
mean i tried for years with my boyfriend
to score it and it's
it it for me it took like going past the
first order i've never been able to
recreate it because every time i'm done
coming i'm just like i'm done i just
want to like shut the computer and like
go to bed and like pull up an asmr video
but
this time i was just so horny for
someone that i was gonna hook up with
like the next night
and that i was like i was like oh go
again
and then i when i doubled up that's when
it happened and it was so exciting and i
like
i remember just like telling everyone i
mean i'm telling everyone now but i was
really really excited that i could do it
but i haven't done it since i mean i
haven't
come in like a month and a half i think
when was uh with the win
that was like two julys ago your brain
is amazing july 3rd 2009 i mean it
really was july 3rd 2019
at the treasure island resort that's
where i probably was
have you ever scored i don't i you would
know i tried
i know we all try yeah i tried like in
my bathtub
to like learn how to do it then i was
like you know what i'm good at a lot of
things
the water level rises slightly yeah
you're in the bath and you just wait for
it to
you know i was like i was just like i i
my vagina's not enough for you
i have fake boobs like i i like i'm i'm
getting my butt if you want it
like i don't like i don't need to beat
myself up over this
no no no no yeah i i just i i
couldn't but i couldn't believe it
happened i had given up and it wasn't
something i was like
somebody sent me a video a guy friend of
mine sent me a video or showed me a
video of a girl of
his girl squirting uh
and it was like it was like plastic bags
yes and i just i don't it looked
um scary yeah it's a lot
i was like i don't want that in my
brooklyn sheets yes but it's a it's an
ultimate it looks like a mess
it's just like a mat it looks unhygienic
yeah it's it looks like a weird
um remember the song by live lightning
crashes
yeah the one that's like written about
the oklahoma city bombing her placenta
falls to yes it's like well you're water
breaking yeah like i know it feels like
it feels pregnancy yeah yeah like i'm
good
it's just like the feeling of it like
you're just like okay am i gonna
like it's but i have problems with
orgasms so
really victorious i feel like my anxiety
about ruining my sheets because i have a
scarcity complex growing up
uh without money that i i couldn't enjoy
whatever the joy is because i'd be like
this is ruining my mattress and does it
go through the mattress like i would i
wouldn't be able to
yeah so much if it's mental yeah that's
i mean that's
my yeah that's always my biggest fear
about coming is like that i'm gonna shit
everywhere it's every that's i can't do
it because i'm so
like with a guy i'm always scared i'm
gonna shit i have to be with i have to
find someone who
if i shit i'll be like that's okay if i
should yeah because i really feel like
that's
gonna you have to date like doctors like
er who have seen it
kidding yep not kidding yeah who like
nothing would grow somehow
fuck blood shit gross things happen
to them yeah you need to date like a
like a paramedic
okay or a serial killer yeah
yes i think i have um
yeah i think i have are you having sex
right now yes
oh that's so good yeah that's great
like how often pretty pretty
yeah pretty regularly oh that's great i
know i've been like a quarantined trauma
bond
with a medical professional okay okay so
you have some experience yeah
what i didn't say anything what really
you didn't do anything
really yeah roll the tape you thought
the tape the film yeah
roll it um okay what i mean this is we i
mean i could do this forever and we
probably will
yeah you're starting another show
we're not allowed to talk about it yeah
yeah i'm starting another podcast
that'll be out in march
but i can't oh it's like a big fucking
yeah why are you why don't you live here
um because i just uh
i mean i'm scared
and to commit to another place why i
don't know
i just want to be in st louis for right
that's dope well that is actually dope i
think i like being around my family
that's awesome that's normal i don't
know that it's normal i feel like
none of us like teenagers are
their
once a year that's what's weird yeah i
didn't i've
really liked being around my family i've
you know nephews and yeah
that's dope it's awesome and yeah that's
that is normal that is healthy that is
grounding that is
how we're designed to be yeah but yeah
i'm all
when this whole thing lifts and life
goes back to normal i'll probably be
back here and i'm really like it's it's
about where i find the most friends so
honestly like coming here and working
towards a friendship with you
is a motivating factor in me living here
like if if if i like i'm like oh there's
a solid friend there that i can rely on
but i would be reasonable i come with
like a very deep
crew no i know of bees do you know what
i mean
what do you mean like if you're friends
with me you've got like 10 other people
that would die for you i know it's
really it's intimidating too
i don't love you oh yeah
oh the best yeah and i want to get in
that sauna with you guys and take
pictures
every time you take a picture with her
you'll get on page six really let's just
like pump up this career
let's just like bump it yeah i mean
that's the girls but
not go to the grocery store without
getting a
page six i don't know daily mail
everything about everything she does
jared everything she does
except for eating burgers with me but
that's fine when you guys hang out
nothing happens
so yeah you'll have like an alliance of
like
warrior bitches yeah like kill for you i
just want
good friends i don't even know that i
ever need a man like i really love
friends so much like
i i just yeah i love myself and as soon
as you stop eating something you'll
yeah yeah you know i'm finally at that
place so i'm like where is it
yeah i know as soon as you stop looking
for your keys like there are my keys
yeah it's just some fucked up yeah
i can't find my contacts so i can't see
anything but one day
one day they'll be there remember when
you forgot your shoes
my wallet you forgot yourself oh yeah we
were doing that yeah my other shoes
is like the most high functioning person
i know and then every now and then
he'll be like sorry i'm late i forgot my
shoe that's like only a thing that
happens in a nightmare
like that's like a really i had to bring
two pair and i only had
my house shoes and he like showed up and
he was like
you weren't like at trader joe's shit a
shoe that was appropriate
okay it was just like he'll just be like
i left my wallet at target it was like
something that's just like
wild you don't do that you don't lose
things
i lose shit all the time i mean that's
eight i used to by the way i was with um
my oldest oldest friend uh uh nick who
makes appearances every now and then in
stories here where he was like remember
when he used to
when i was 22. remember you used to
throw your wallet
uh into a trash can and coffee bean once
a week and we'd have to go through this
i'd have to dumpster dive after
performing at the comedy store i'd have
to dumpster dive
through uh trash at a coffee bean or a
starbucks
yeah inside my wallet i mean this
happened like right this is why i put
stickers on everything now and i'm gonna
put stickers on my phone
what do you mean you can't make i don't
i don't do black i'm over black
like things no black stand out no black
phone no black wallet
oh yeah yeah neon pink stickers glitter
catch the eye and i have this is a
necklace
yeah so it's i'm not losing this thing
yeah i don't give a shit
i'll get a fanny pack is we're very
close to a fanny pack did you have that
podcast it's up here like this
that there's got to be a better way no
no
there's no no this says successful
this is habit the better way is where's
my phone
chad can someone call it it's on silent
i mean
yeah this is the best case scenario yeah
are you
i lose everything necklace shay maybe no
dude i just need the portable charger to
have your necklace on
like i have your shirt on i have your
knuckles this was my dream by the way i
like came over
kind of dressed like shit just so you'd
be like do you want something else like
i
wanted you to offer me your throat the
other day we did a show
and you were like i don't know and then
i walk in and then i made fun of it
and i am such and i was on you caught me
at such a bad time too because i was
already feel like
i was having anything there and i was
with paris hilton who is
so stunning in person like she's as
stunning in person as you would
as in on on print and
she had someone touching her up every 10
minutes but i didn't have anyone and
they couldn't even touch me because of
covid
so i was just like eight hours in like
haggard like
raccoon eyes and like frizzy and like my
shirt was untucked and she kept like
tucking
it back in and i was just like i didn't
hire stylists this time because i was
like i'm just going to try to do it on
my own
and and save a thousand bucks and
actually get to keep the clothes
no offense to them they do great work i
remember walking in and be like she
looks cold
oh my god i was like i think that's on
backwards like i was just started like
oh my god i just like to say it's
happening again yes it was like i was
like so insecure and then you
just that was the thing you said
everything that i was already thinking
people are gonna think about me and you
were just like can we get another hole
in nicki's shirt
does anyone have any scissors look at
your flyaways is anyone even looking at
her
because by the way you look like a mess
and i was just like
hi whitney and then you go to paris you
go and you
stay perfection perfection yeah and i
was like
no and i looked at you and i think i
said fuck you yeah
it was real it was real it was that was
a real one it was fair and it was
deserved
no but i felt like your boyfriend at
that family dinner
i was really i was i was hurt and then
but then i was hurt
because i do a thing in my stories if
you fucking watch my stories and if you
didn't mute me
i do a thing where i make fun of
sweaters that have a fucking shoulder
cut out of them because i don't
understand what season it is that's like
my hair has a good shoulder whitney it's
a whole
lot that's that's your makes yes i do
have good shoulders a lot of
all the things that i used to do i think
your theory was well if you would pay
more attention to me i wouldn't have
hurt your feelings
[Music]
i think if we would have made this more
about me you wouldn't be so hurt
i'm hilarious if you were just right
though if you knew more about me you
would
know that why that was funny i don't
have an extra two hours every day to
spend watching your
stories but um yeah that was something i
had to pay for those sweaters i'm giving
you the fact that i was able to be like
fuck you
that was like oh my god we're friends
because there's usually i'd go like
it was so fun and be like that was like
and i would swallow it and then
bitch about it later and instead i was
able to tell you how i felt in that
moment
process it and then later on you were
like i that was
and and we just had them it just felt
good it felt like i was like that's
that's how i talk to my friends
that was that's not how i used to talk
to whitney cummings i would just like
want you to like me and be like oh yeah
but i was just like
no it was also like it was also just
like this is my whole thing like wrong
time wrong time
right thing wrong time you could have
pulled should have pulled her aside
also you're not directing i like my t
like tears formed in my eyes i was just
having like such a day where i'm like
i'm
ugly and i like how about standing next
to
bulldozer but then i felt so relaxed
like after that with you and i felt like
i don't know i i was those moments where
you're like oh i
actually expressed what i was feeling
when i was feeling it like
had a feeling had an actual feeling
instead of suppressing the like yeah
sadness and got it out i got it out and
that's what pray animals do that's what
horses do they fucking claim their space
and they move on and they forgive right
dogs
best friends again yes like that's what
humans we hold on to that shit and it's
so boring and gives us cancer
yeah it does and um yeah so it was it
was a good moment
it made me feel like oh she's a good
friend of mine because i was able to
talk to you like a sister
so cool yeah in front the whole crew was
like i know i
i like i almost did it i i reacted in a
way that made people uncomfortable
because i
i think i was letting out a lot of
aggression in that mo like a lot of just
it was frustrating because the whole day
was i was filled with insecurities when
you're a comedian and you feel like you
don't know how to be funny and you're
with
someone that's not a comedian and you
like kind of have your kid gloves on and
you don't want to hurt
them but you still want to be funny but
you don't make fun of them and
then you have to self-deprecate which
we're not doing anymore
i know that's that's really tasty it's
like you have your hands tied behind
your back and you're like i'm not being
funny so my only thing i do right now is
be pretty and i can't even fucking be
that
yes yes that is it
yeah not being able to self-deprecate
anymore like liking myself
that's gonna i'm gonna lose but no no
but you but you can if it's
funny yeah almost done don't that's true
that's and if it's true it's and if it's
true but like
we still get to be funny and also we're
grandfathered in like my generation we
didn't have fucking jay shetty and brene
brown and all this shit okay like we
didn't have self
we're allowed to have low self-esteem
we're allowed to say
oh god this looks ridiculous like don't
talk to yourself like that don't fucking
talk to me
i am your elder
they i will say whatever the fuck i want
about myself you know
yes i i choose to not exhaust other
people with my self-deprecating
pity me shit okay yeah people don't
yeah then it puts them in a shitty
situation and it really is just
that's a bad example but i am allowed to
say like because i shouldn't have had
those weed blueberries like i can do
that
yeah i can call myself out it's good i
don't want to self-deprecate
yeah we're the best
we put makeup on now that the interview
is ending do you want to end it
whitney this has been um a great podcast
because it's
it's we've gotten serious you got
teary-eyed i would have but i don't feel
my feelings i'm on prozac so i didn't
really saw oh yeah that was emotional
about i don't want to bring it up okay
side of the road i'm over it um yeah so
um i really wanted to
um fuck you're too interesting i really
wanted us to go through our old specials
and talk show appearances
we really wanted to do and kind of roast
ourselves didn't and i was trying to
steer the conversation away from it so i
wouldn't have to look at it i almost
think it's maybe a couple more people
should do it with us
yeah it shouldn't just be us so that it
doesn't feel so like
yes yes you know i think it'd be good
for me to do
because i don't watch like i've never
watched you remember a pop-up video
yeah on each one it's like that maybe
it's a show maybe it's like yeah
where we all look at our old talk show
appearances and just like remember when
bill burr was on
um conan there was a new stage and he um
uh uh it was like the mic was really far
away and the music
the band stopped and then he was like
started like running to the mic and he
was like oh jesus i didn't think i was
gonna make it
like he just misjudged this yeah he
didn't get to have a sound check and it
was just this funny moment
where like like something always goes
wrong yeah and there's always some weird
and i think it'd be interesting just to
take it apart and be like oh this was
the story of that day this is what i i
was what i
this is where i picked up that outfit
this is who and by the way right before
the show they told me i wasn't allowed
to say jesus christ and then i
ruined the whole joke and i wasn't
allowed to say asshole so i had to say
dumb
uh head yeah and it just like totally
bombed
you know just like all that i walked
over the couch after my first night show
and it was uh
rain wilson was the the other guest and
i walked over and i said he was like
good job and i go thanks dwight
and i didn't catch it until i watched it
later i was like oh god by the way
that's so
funny though thanks dwight and he thinks
you're a genius
it was yeah and oh man that's so funny
that was i can't wait to watch that one
with you thanks dwight yeah it's also
like
and i didn't who says like when benton
gives me something i'm not like thanks
benton
like why did you wanted to say why did
you say any name i was so confident
about it
it's such a weird thing to do you're
like thanks jimmy
uh like back to you like your local news
yeah well it's been fun whitney love you
don't write elephants uh nikki glazer
all the instagram
[Music]
[Applause]